- Welcome back everybody,
The cast of Bros is with us,
Billy Eichner, Symone, Luke
Macfarlane and Jim Rash.
(applause)
To celebrate their new movie
we wanted to play a game to
honor the LGBTQ+ community,
and Billy was kind enough to
choose a game called Cher the Love.
- Okay.
- See.
♪ Cher the Love♪
(windchimes chime)
- Favorite part of this show
is Jesse managed to make her
way up to the fireman, it's my favorite.
- For Bells.
- I love it.
It's just like, Oh, I
need to, for the music.
Jim Rash agreed to host.
Teams are Luke and me
versus Billy and Symone.
Basically, I just, it seemed
like really fun to beat Billy
so that's why I did it like this.
- Wow.
- Oh yeah, it's on.
- Bring it on Kelly Clarkson.
- It's on Eichner!
- Thank you.
- So the floor is now
yours Jim, take it away.
How does the game go?
- If I may, just real quick
because this could be great audition tape
for game show host.
Hi, Jim Rash, 5'9.
I'm Los Angeles based
and I'm auditioning for
the role of game show host.
- Very Good.
- Could be it. 5'9, it might be debatable.
All right, here we go.
Based on this shot where I am.
Okay, here we go.
The game is simple.
I'll ask a question
about a gay icon of which there are many.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And whichever team can
be the first to buzz in
and give the correct answer, gets a point,
but answer wrong and the
other team can steal.
So let's be careful.
Now you can answer before I'm done reading
but I have a lovely speaking voice
so that might be
disappointing to everybody
but it will cost you,
okay, if you get it wrong.
Okay. So if Billy and Symone win
their photos will be ceremoniously mounted
on the Chicks Wall of
Champs Who Beat Kelly.
(trumpets, applause)
- Whatever.
- [Jim] Okay.
- Okay. It's a dumb wall.
- [Jim] That's how it goes.
- [Symone] Win the prize to beat Kelly.
- And away we go.
- Okay. Come on Luke! Okay.
- Hands hovering or
somewhere near the buzzer.
Okay. First question.
Before she enjoyed the View
or even had her own talk show
this comedic icon was
in a league of her own.
- Rosie O'Donald. I knew
it from the beginning.
- Dammit. Dammit.
- Dammit!
- [Jim] Okay.
- [Kelly] I'm feeling good.
I'm feeling good. Feeling good.
- [Jim] Okay One, Zero.
- [Billy] Yeah, I get it, Jim. I get it.
- It says, It says to judge.
Okay. Wait.
Next question.
This icon released her album
Renaissance this summer.
- Beyonce.
- Hey!
- Oh, you, That was so quick.
That was so quick.
- [Jim] All you had to
say was win or loss,
that's all I need to hear.
- [Kelly] I know, I
know, I know. I was slow.
- These buzzers are working flawlessly.
Okay, next question.
He was the first openly
gay man to be elected
to public office in California.
And a- Yes.
- Harvey. Harvey Milk.
- That is correct.
- Milk. Oh man, I knew that one.
- [Jim] Two points.
- Wow.
- He's in the movie.
- [Jim] One.
- [Kelly] God. Okay. Okay.
Okay, okay, okay. Okay.
- Two points, One.
- We got this, we got this, we got this.
- It's good for a host to judge
the people who are losing.
All right, next question.
This New York born icon
reminded us all that we're
on the right track, baby,
because we are born-
- Born This Way.
Lady Gaga. Bam!
- [Luke] Yeah! Boom.
- [Jim] It is time to do
Okay, next question.
- I kind of hit you hard.
- No, it's fine, I contributed nothing.
- That was very aggressive.
- Get in there, Luke.
Don't be afraid.
Here we go.
- Luke is like Tim McGraw.
- George Fraise.
- We're both, we're all-
- Randy Travis.
- [Kelly] Another great-
- One of these will be a country star.
Here we go.
Next Question. This
iconic vocalist was born
with four extra teeth
in the back of his mouth
and never had them fixed
because he was afraid
it would ruin his voice.
- What?
- I'm gonna guess Freddie Mercury.
- That is right.
- What? Who knew that?
- [Billy] I didn't know that.
- I'd never heard that.
- Three points, two.
- We're kind of amazing.
- Okay, Here we go.
- Yeah, that's-
- Next question.
If you are, if you are
Billy Eichner, good luck.
You saw her in concert with your parents.
Oh.
- Oh. Barbara Streisand
- Oh guess who listened.
- You shouldn't have answered!
- [Kelly] Guess who listened!
- That's cause I can listen!
- Wow.
- That was another Beyonce song.
- Could not even know
about you fast enough.
All right, here we go, it is four two.
All right.
This icon was the first
drag queen to get his star
on the Hollywood walk of, Yes.
- Well, I'ma go Ru Paul.
- Yeah.
- It is four three.
And this is the last question.
However, it is worth seven points.
- Why?
Okay.
- All right.
This icon was the first
woman to win the album
of the year Grammy over two decades
after she dropped a house on a witch.
(muttering)
- Oh God.
- [Luke] I got, I got it!
- Judy Garland! Judy Garland.
- I don't know how long time is.
- Judy Garland, Judy Garland.
I was thinking her daughter,
Liza.
(air horn)
I was like, not Liza, not Liza.
- I didn't know how long we waiting as
the host I get to make that call.
- I kept wanting to say, I was saying,
Liza, I was like the
mother, the mother! Judy.
- Yeah. That's okay.
- You know how intense I am.
Wow. Sweating.
(laughter)
- So that sound that I did not
hear means the game is over.
(laughter)
- And Kelly and Luke are the winners.
- It looks like we're the
winners! We're the winners.
Thank you for playing everybody.
The effort was appreciated.
I'm just kidding!
Once again, Bros opens
in theaters tomorrow.